Coffee at 4 a.m. on a Saturday night and
blog 28 so tonight we are on the set of
my very good friend no Banaras new short
film Motel blues tonight we're filming
at the pear blossom motel of about 60
miles north of Los Angeles and we have
the whole motel rented out for the night
which by the way is one of the coolest
things about independent filmmaking and
filmmaking in general is that you get to
use real locations like this and
repurpose them for your movie tonight I
want to show you what goes into making a
short film of this stature and one thing
you should understand is that the only
difference between this and a movie you
might see at your local AMC is the
amount of money in the budget the way
this film is being made is the way all
films are made a big-budget blow it
might have you know more people on the
crew more freedom with time and
locations and equipment but all the
necessary stuff is here and it's left
like all films to the actors the story
the filming techniques and the vision of
the director but let me let me introduce
you to the crew let's let's stay busy
okay so first we have the unit
production manager or UPF whose job it
is to manage the production from before
the filming - after you PM will create a
working budget before principal
photography and do her level best to
make sure that the final cost doesn't go
too much over the mark on smaller
productions the upm is also responsible
for hiring a casting agent as well as
anyone else the crew might need in short
this person sails the ship as calmly as
she can
toward principal photography when the
assistant director or ad assumes the job
as on set organizer the ad maintains
order on the set as hooligans from every
department run this way and that to
arrange the shot the ad writes and sends
out call sheets which are schedules for
the days of shooting and the AE calls
out necessary commands before the shot
starts it sounds sort of like this all
right no audio roll camera next we have
the sound recordings quite possibly the
most overlooked underrated an important
job on an indie film set it's difficult
to communicate just how much sound
determines the way we perceive a movie
filmmaking gets branded as largely a
visual medium but poorly recorded sound
can destroy an otherwise great project
to record good sound good dialogue which
means recording all the many frequencies
of the human voice the recordists uses a
boom or lavalier mic to get as close to
the actors mouths as possible this
requires coordination with the DP and
the director making sure that they set
up the shot so that the recordist can
position his mic close but out of print
next we have the gaffer and his
assistant the best boy these gentlemen
are responsible for lighting a movie and
as a film is essentially a combination
of light and darkness their
responsibility is huge film lighting is
exceedingly tricky because the camera
lens sees differently than the eye and
the gaffer must understand that often
irrational relationship between the two
when you have a talented one like our
friend Justin here who can work quickly
to produce stunning images you simply
put up with his embarrassing personality
because she's met Toby Jack next we have
hair and makeup and the art director
hair and makeup is responsible for
making the actors look good and the art
director has that same responsibility
for the set the art director can take an
otherwise bland space and create the
appropriate
with furniture trinkets whatever he can
find there's nothing and art director
likes more than a thrift store full of
other people's throwaway junk next we
have the assistant camera people those
quiet warriors who serve as the third
fourth fifth and sixth hands of the DP
the camera department must assemble the
camera attach it to whatever tripod or
rig will be used for the shot in
question and perform that daunting and
also underappreciated task known as
focus pulling see a camera lens can only
focus on one cross-section of space away
from the camera it being a larger small
cross-section depending on the lens and
the light if either the actors or the
camera is moving during the shot the
noble focus puller must buy soft
adjustments of the lens make sure the
talent stays within the given
cross-section or depth of field it's
like a game the most infuriating game
ever created all the work done by the
gaffer his assistant and the camera
department is done to satisfy the
demands of the director of photography
or DP working closely with the director
and being his first partner the DP
determines the shot how it will be lit
how the camera will move what the
framing will be all in an effort to
serve the needs of the story everything
a camera does is felt by the audience
and the DP must understand and
manipulate the rules of composition that
we might feel what the story wants us to
feel the DP directs our attention to
what we need to say the other job of the
DP always make the actors look good the
actors supply the human element to a
film they take written characters and
make them real for the audience to love
or hate whatever the story demands they
are subservient to the director but
often is the case that actors being
students of human behavior find a way to
present their characters which the
director would never have thought of in
which in fact served his ends better
it's important therefore to give actors
freedom to find what's real in the
dialogue and action written for them
after all the audience will never see
the script they will see the actors and
nine times out of ten the performances
are what they'll be talking about on the
car ride home and finally we get to the
most important part of a film the part
on which everything else hinges craft
services yes where the food is it's
perhaps impossible to say what a film
shoot can become if the crew is not
satiated
it starts with whispers of maltreatment
wines and backtalk sharp attitudes and
shouting before you know it someone is
throwing a 1k at
directors head for goodness sakes feed
your crew if it's possible spoil them
the respect and quality work you'll get
in return will be worth it and lastly
the director though a film might
sometimes start its journey to the
theater at the pen of a screenwriter and
though in unhappy circumstances it may
end its journey with the discretion of a
producer there is no question that the
artist of a film the one whose vision
the rest are trying to realize is the
director in its purest form a director
plays all the parts I just mentioned
that of writer director and trump card
holder in large budget pictures this is
rarely the case and there have been
plenty of fine films made in that system
but the characteristic quality of
low-budget film especially no budget
short films is that necessity requires
that the director does indeed play all
these parts including that of the editor
here we really get to see what's in the
filmmakers heart and how he translates
it to the screen
but no air is escaping these sleeves
like I could be submerged in my arms be
dry
god Bless America god bless america
Korean are we ready gonna shoot it it's
a sham